the Eggman called the voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P and said you
know we cater to delusions all the time
Republicans keep talking about catering
to delusions when it comes to trans but
what about the fact that all these
Republicans are constantly catering to
delusions from Christianity when it
comes to making law in the United States
the Eggman says it much more eloquently
than I do
Tulsi gubard to Kaylee mcanoodles said
that catering to the delusions of the
trans people is just bad politics
because it's such a small population
if they were delusions she's absolutely
correct Dave however catering to the
delusions of the Christian slash
Catholic God Believers is good politics
ask Trump
Shalom right
right yeah no there is a double standard
and we know that there is a double
standard when it comes to well
you know uh uh Corinthians and John and
Paul they say the following about
poverty or abortion or gay marriage and
we should be taken seriously when in a
civil government proceeding we invoke
our scripture
to influence what the law should be take
us seriously well but a lot of people
don't believe that you could you could
say that that is a religious delusion of
yours that you're imposing on everybody
else and saying listen to me
go by what I believe based on the
supposed sacred nature of the text that
I'm probably misunderstanding anyway but
then when it comes to trans then they
have a very different perspective the
Eggman is absolutely correct I have very
little to add we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today we will talk about
Paul goes are facing questions over a
staffer's alleged far-right links we
will talk about the new IRS free
e-filing system that the tax prep Giants
are Furious about and vice media once
worth more than five billion dollars has
filed for bankruptcy the latest in the
media downfall that is afflicting many
BuzzFeed news and others all of it on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com you'll get instant access
otherwise I'll see you back here
tomorrow